we all know that the last two years were
really a battle for everyone especially
it affected the daily lives of every
working individual or soon to be part of
the corporate world but every cloud has
a silver lining because everyone was at
home exploring and trying their hands on
different aspects for earning their
living and today in 2022 this demand
opened the way to various hidden but
in-trend jobs or profiles and thus
considering this demand an urge to learn
simply learn has brought you a new video
on the highest paying jobs of 2023 to
Enlighten you with in-demand job
profiles and to help you get a better
perspective on what's the coming future
holds for you
these jobs don't require you to have a
degree Yes you heard it right you don't
need a college degree to start with
these jobs
till the end of the video to find out
which job profile pays the highest so
without any further Ado let's start the
video
at the eighth position in our list is
customer support specialist
customer support Specialists are in
charge of identifying and resolving
consumer issues while still acting
professionally and courteously customer
service Representatives must be
detail-oriented have excellent
communication skills be able to focus
Under Pressure set priorities and handle
multiple inquiries at the same time this
is typically a full-time position in an
office setting now if somebody wants to
start their career as a customer support
specialist they must have computer
skills like data entry internal tracking
and ticketing Etc also many customer
service positions don't require
certification but having industry
certification can help demonstrate their
expertise to hiring managers
now come into the exciting part which is
salary so a customer support specialist
earns roughly 45
000 in the US and approximately five
lakhs per annum in India
so this was all about customer support
specialist
now moving on to the seventh position on
our list which is a flight attendant a
flight attendant is someone who takes
care of passengers on airplanes
the primary responsibility of a flight
attendant is to ensure that everyone on
board an airplane is safe and
comfortable
a person pursuing a career as a flight
attendant is counted as a cabin crew
member
now talking about some of the essential
skills for a flight attendant are good
communication skills Pleasant
personality and interpersonal skills Etc
so if one wants to start their career as
a flight attendant it is favorable if
they have expertise in Hospitality food
and beverage service after that you can
undergo a training course and
certification
now talking about the salary a flight
attendant earns approximately 48 000 in
the U.S and in India they can earn
roughly 12 lakhs per annum so now let's
move to another interesting job which is
content creator a content creator is
someone who develops amusing or
educational information since most of
the content is consumed digitally
content creation is especially relevant
to digital content
as a content creator it is expected of
them to manage social media accounts and
respond to client queries and comments
digital marketing materials and articles
can all be considered forms of content
creation for businesses sharing content
ideas with various corporate departments
to help with their content requirements
is also a Content Creator's
responsibility now to become a content
creator one must have knowledge of SEO
social media marketing affiliate
marketing Etc you can also try to create
a network by offering to work or by
collaborating now comes the salary on an
average a content creator earns up to
fifty thousand dollars per annum in the
US and 7.2 lakhs per annum in India
and number five we have graphic designer
so a graphic designer designs Graphics
that clients May print or submit to
their website using both digital graphic
design software and conventional art
mediums including pencil pen and paint
graphic designers create a wide range of
visual assets including logos signage
magazine layouts advertising report
templates and advertisements they could
specialize in a specific area of graphic
design or offer General Graphic Design
Services to clients the tools used by a
graphic designer include Adobe
Illustrator Adobe Photoshop Pixlr canva
Etc
now to become a graphic designer one can
opt for some online courses join a
design community and can also gain some
practical experience through internships
a graphic designer earns up to fifty
thousand dollars per annum in the US and
6.5 lakh per annum in India now let's
move on to another interesting job which
is digital marketer
digital marketing is the promotion of
Brands to engage with potential
customers over the Internet other
digital communication channels are known
as digital marketing commonly referred
to as online marketing
digital marketers produce advertising
campaigns for customers or for the
business in whose marketing department
they are employed
they work in advertising agencies or
marketing departments so if you want to
start your career as a digital marketer
you must have an accurate view of the
market one can also enroll in
certification and boot camps for digital
marketing now a digital marketer earns
roughly 62 000 in the US and 6.7 lakh
per annum in India so now let's move on
to the top three job profiles with the
third one being the executive assistant
an executive assistant is a
secretary-like administrative
professional the job generally requires
client relations handling information
requests preparing statistical reports
event planning Etc big businesses like
Deloitte and Amazon employ the majority
of executive assistants
so if someone wants to start a career as
an executive assistant they must have a
high school diploma there are also some
certifications available such as
certified administrative professional
certified professional secretary and
advanced certificate for executive
assistant that will help them broaden
their skill set
now comes to the interesting part which
is the salary an executive assistant
owns roughly 63 000 in the US and
approximately 5.19 lakh per annum in
India
so let's have a look at the profile on
second position and that is the real
estate agent
a real estate agent is a qualified
individual who coordinates real estate
transactions by connecting buyers and
sellers and representing them in
discussions
the ability to close a deal impacts how
much money a real estate agent makes
their commissions which is frequently a
percentage of the property's purchase
price make up the majority of their
income
the job requires staying updated with
real estate markets showing properties
to buyers Council and clients Etc so if
you want to become a real estate agent
you must understand your State's
requirements complete the pre-licensing
work apply for a real estate exam and
maintain the real estate license and
then you can work with the firm the
interesting part will now be revealed
which of course is the salary a real
estate agent earns roughly 68 000 in the
US and approximately 5.7 lakhs per annum
in India now moving on to the number one
position on our list with maximum salary
and that is a web developer so now let's
take a look at it so web developers
utilize web-facing technology to design
software to create and maintain websites
and web applications working with
graphic designers on site layout problem
solving and testing this job requires
troubleshooting problems of the website
monitoring the website creating test
applications
Etc the scope of a web developer's work
might vary depending on their area of
expertise and specialization so if you
want to become a web developer you must
enroll in a course practice on the skill
apply for web developer options as it's
one of the most searched specialist jobs
in the market a web developer earns a
whopping seventy thousand dollars in the
US and approximately 7.7 lakhs per annum
in India
with that we have reached the end of
this video on highest paying jobs that
don't require a degree which one would
you choose let us know in the comments
section below if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to Simply learn on
YouTube
I hope it really helps you all thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
foreign
[Music]